[Music]
it's not the be all and end all though
not at all I think I think you could
actually end up making it something that
works for you you can a classy woman
with tattoo does some Intrigue that
could be interesting so I'm not we're
not giving you like some kind of final
judgment yeah it's not a death sentence
at all just just get a couple of sun
dresses
F in this room hated my tattoos I love
them they're great tattoos they love
they're beautiful yeah I personally
don't have a thing against tattoo but
I'm not going to lie if I saw someone
with tattoos it doesn't scream take me
out to dinner
talk to me every night treat me like
wifey It kind of screams like you've
probably had two or three toxic
relationships like you know yeah I get
where you're that's my first impression
it's not you're on the journey you know